madame monsieur bonjour l'image de la
semaine c'est la poignée de main de
trois hommes Lionel Jospin Jacques
Lafleur et roc wamitan trois mains
croisées qui cellent l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie vers une plus large
autonomie cette image restera le symbole
d'une évolution négociée de l'État
français et de ses anciennes colonies
mais cet accord ne résout pas tout car
il n'a pas vous allez voir la même
signification pour tout le monde
Nathalie noziier je suis persuadé que
dans 20 ans les Calédoniens et les
calédoniennes choisiront
de demeurer au sein de la République
l'indépendance ce n'est pas pendant 20
ans elle commence à se construire dès
aujourd'hui en signant l'accord de numea
FLNKS et RPCR espèrent conforter leur
position l'objectif à long terme reste
le même pour chacun l'indépendance ou le
maintien du lien avec la France un
clivage qui semble se retrouver dans la
population au marché de Nea lieu où se
croisent des gens de toutes origines on
commente l'accord qui dans l'ensemble
mais que pass dans 20
ans pas les mê rép
[Musique]
pourépend mais il faut faire faut
d'abord préparer les hommes comme si on
estarmée dans une guerreabord préparer
les hommes pour aller sur le
terrain des hommes de dem moi je suis
cdoch qu générations descendant de
bagnard d'un côté pas de côté un côté
libre un côté Bagard ben moi je pense
que c'est pas une mauvaise chose et puis
de toute façon c'est nous qui allons
décider donc si on veut pas être
indépendant dans 20 ans on sera pas
indépendant si ça devient
indépendant ça se passera comme dans
tous les autres pays pays où il sont
indépendants que maintenant ils
regrettent c'est sûr pour le moment les
deux discours coexistent dans 15 ou 20
ans un référendum y apportera une
réponse en attendant le FLNKS et le RPCR
de gérer ensemble leur pays avec les
nouvelles compétences qui leur seront
progressivement attribuées le vrai défi
pour tous reste d'inventer un avenir
commun